do generally man you can really figure
out so much about where you're messing
up in life in which you need to fix
about yourself do it anyway is a mindset
trick that you can use when you start to
feel excuses rolling up what cat not
just improves your physics it also helps
your mind we're gonna read wanna be
happy
build a life not just the business
every single day we're cutting it out so
loving you and I believe in life ball
hey seven Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the habits you
must develop if you want to be a success
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one Journal with David Goggins I write
down my day and what I do is I go back
and study that day like sometimes I
might I might get sick I might be over
trained I might gain a couple pounds
here I might feel it whatever that and I
it's like my accountability journal of
what I'm doing with my life physical
mental I had eating journal audition and
helps me go back to once again study I'm
a lab rat and I studied myself I'm not
feeling up I go okay what I do last week
and usually I can find out where I
messed up last week you know how much
time travel I'm less I'm sleep and how
much something all this stuff and and
through journaling man you can really
figure out so much about where you're
messing up in life in which you need to
fix about yourself taking constant
inventory cos being honest about that
and that's thing but you cannot put
bullets in there yeah it's gotta be a
real a real journal about a today I
messed up here today I should have been
a better person here and not just saying
it but actually trying to fix it
tomorrow how about number two use the do
it anyway strategy with Mel Robbins do
it anyway is a mindset trick that you
can use when you start to feel excuses
rolling up it works a lot like the
five-second rule so you have said to
yourself okay I'm gonna talk to my boss
today about that thing that I've been
avoiding talking to them about or maybe
you've said something like I'm gonna go
to the gym today or tomorrow or whatever
and then the moment comes where you've
got to have that conversation or the
moment comes where it's time to pack up
your bag and leave your desk and go to
Jim and what always happens you don't
feel like it I bet there are plenty of
you watching that have made a commitment
that yeah I'm not gonna have a drink
today and then guess what happens when
you get home you don't feel like not
drinking you feel like having a drink
and so here's what do it anyway has done
for me the idea that I just do it anyway
has pushed me to realize and to
recognize that there are a lot of
moments where there are things in my
life that I really want to do I need to
do I should do but when the moment comes
I don't feel like it and so I pull out
this idea of you know what I'm just
gonna do it anyway it's raining outside
I said I would go for a short run I
don't feel like it I'm gonna do it
anyway it's six o'clock in the morning
I'm tired it's cold I laid out my yoga
clothes but now I don't feel like it
what do I do I do it
anyway when you start to say to yourself
I'm gonna do it anyway what happens is
something really cool you acknowledge
that there are feelings that you have
that are trying to swoop in and hijack
you you acknowledge them and you
basically say guess what I'm gonna do it
anyway habit number three work out with
mani Cashman if your see
self-improvement not even just with cars
with your own body you know when you go
work out do you feel better when they
come out of gym all pumped up or you
feel better when you haven't worked out
for a month yeah of course you know you
have any good there Jim you know you're
building your you know something happens
when you see changes in your body with
your assets when you see even gaining a
good friend I have my down days you know
I'm sure you do - we're all human you
know you could have all the money in the
world you're still gonna have a bad day
absolutely you don't know what's gonna
cause
you know you do and you know for me
working out is great I have a personal
trainer three times a week and then when
I don't have my personal trainer I just
get out of bed and drop on the floor and
do 20 push-ups 30 push-ups do I do it
until I can do it anymore and then I hit
the shower and I feel great you know
yeah and it's you know it's just keeping
the fluids going you know your mind
fresh yeah because work at not just
improves your physics it also helps your
mind we're gonna read and sometimes it
helps your mentality more than your
physique but people don't realize that
you know it helps you focus you know
also if you want more motivation and
self-love check out my 254 series
they're free the link to join on the
description below everything I didn't
want to do is what got me to where I'm
at today
our minds are designed to stop you at
all costs from doing anything that might
hurt you my dreams are first everyday
then my wife then my kids I could take
care of my wife and my kids now would
you agree I abandoned this this is the
fuel for Who I am
how about number four become a great
reader with Oprah Winfrey and I would
say reading is the strongest signal for
success in the future that I've ever
seen it is the strongest strongest
strongest I got my first job in radio
when I was 16 years old tough because
I've been in broadcasting since I was 16
years old but my first job I got because
I was a great reader when you are a
great reader you can articulate and
speak and command the English language
in ways that other people cannot and
people think you're a lot smarter than
you are
lots of times because you're great
reader have you ever met a person who
was a great reader when they were young
who was not successful you never never
it is the absolute best foundation ever
in life habit number five beat the Sun
up with grant cardone grant rant of the
day the one you need to live with wake
up to every day is that right there
okay beat the Sun up folks you got to
beat the Sun up if you can't beat up the
roll up of the Sun up you're gonna get
beat up in life okay I've been doing
this for a long time now say beat that
thing up that monster out there that
warms this planet that nourishes and
gives us light you can't live it to next
life if you're not beating the Sun up so
many of you complain about how much time
you have you don't have time man because
you don't beat the Sun up get started
early and when you get started early
that means you need to shut it down
early okay shut it down or at least so
you get sleep I was asleep last night at
nine o'clock so I could beat the scent
up to mark this morning and see the
world wake up with me habit number six
push yourself with Dan lock in order to
be successful I believe there like many
many habits and develop but I think the
one habit that you must develop that
will change your life that will change
your world is this one thing I want you
to imagine this I want you to kind of
draw a circle if you're watching my
video you are in front of your desk go
ahead and do that I want to draw a big
circle and within the circle I want to
draw everything that you have in your
life right now that you already have
maybe it's the car that you drive the
income that you have the the house that
you live in the the vacation that you
already take the people around you right
involvement doesn't have to be
materialistic but doesn't really matter
what it is the things that you already
have right now you possess in your life
I want to draw that within the circle
write all those things down then I want
you to outside a circle write down
everything that you want in your life
but you don't have okay so maybe now
you're driving a Hyundai and you
actually want a Mercedes okay that's all
there mister so write down a Mercedes
outside a circle maybe you're living in
a condo but you actually want to live in
a big house okay write that outside of a
circle so I want you to write that so
with inner circle is everything that you
have right now outside that circle is
everything that you want but don't have
so I want to look at this right now
what is the circle the circle is your
comfort zone everything you have right
now in your life they are all within
your comfort zone and your comfort zone
is your income zone I want to look at
everything that you want but don't have
where are they they're outside of your
comfort zone depends on what you put it
so in order to get what you want but
don't have in life what do you have to
do you need to stretch and expand your
comfort zone because if it's within your
comfort zone guess what you already have
them so everything that you want in life
that you don't have right now is all
outside of your comfort zone so I
believe the number one habit you need to
devolve to be successful it's on a
consistent if not a daily basis do
things that make you feel uncomfortable
it is that simple because you look at
what holds most people back what holds
you back is fear fear of the unknown
fear of failure fear of rejection fear
of success all these things is all
outside your comfort zone
human being because we're creature of
habits we tend to operate day to day and
do the same thing again and again and
again but if you have a habit you make a
habit that you do things on a consistent
basis that you don't usually do it makes
you scare it scare stuff out of you it
makes you stretch your comfort zone
that's how you gradually expand it and
get more of what you want maybe is going
to the event that you've never been to
maybe is meeting their successful people
that in that intimidates you maybe is
reading a book that you have no interest
reading in maybe it's driving a
different path that you usually call
home this way hey you know what I'm
gonna drive a different path and see
something a little bit different right
maybe it's watching a video that you
don't usually watch may be interested
certain topics maybe you're watching a
youtube video just on prank but
something you watch something that is
out inspiration a motor
that's practical this business-related
and that changes the way that you think
about stuff it started with that one
thing that one video and if you do that
not one time not two times not three
times but hundreds and hundreds of times
on a consistent basis I believe that is
the habit not just to be successful but
to stay successful in habit number seven
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is mixed with successful people
with Bob Procter you've got to mix with
successful people you cannot mix with
people that are going nowhere and expect
you to go somewhere you're just not
going to do it because they just wander
around in circles up until I picked up
thinking Grow Rich oh yeah I had no
goals but the people I hung around with
didn't have any goals you see I was a
product of on my of my environment and I
think everybody else says and the
beautiful truth is we can create our own
environment today the people i mix with
are directed they know exactly where
they're going they're into the right
ideas and they mixed with other very
successful people now I have a special
bonus clip from rich roll on how to
enhance the quality of your sleep that I
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
landing questions let's go from just
watching a video to take an action here
we go question number one
how can you mix with more successful
people this month number two where do
you need to push yourself harder and
number three where can you apply the do
it anyway strategy two and if you made
it this far in the video I want to
celebrate you give me a hashtag believe
down the comments rich why do you sleep
in a tent for those that don't know for
the last two years I've been sleeping
outside in this thing a lot of people
have been asking me why do you do that
and it basically boils down to three
fundamental reasons the first is
I just sleep better in a tent outside
the second reason is that it really has
helped me connect with nature and the
outdoors and I think our primal
disposition and the third reason I've
been doing it is because fundamentally
it's a stoic practice a couple years ago
I started struggling with trying to get
a deep sleep unless I was training
SuperDuper hard I just found it
difficult to get the restfulness that my
body and my mind need and at the time
our bedroom that I share with my wife
Julie was either too cold for her or too
hot for me then I had an experience
where we as a family all slept on our
roof one night we have flat roof and we
did it just for fun with the kids and I
had the most restful peaceful night of
sleep in recent memory being outdoors
breathing that outdoor air sleeping
under the stars is a very simple and
basic way of reconnecting with what it
means to be fundamentally human we live
in this super fast-paced culture you got
to get your hustle on you gotta like
work 24 hours a day and if you're not
being productive in every moment of your
waking existence then you're wasting
time and you're falling behind and with
that comes a deep prioritization of
sleep sleep is for slackers right and
nothing could be further from the truth
I know that I can't perform at my very
best unless I get eight hours of sleep
and it's not just the amount of time
that I sleep it's the quality of that
sleep it's the caliber of that sleep it
is my opinion that everybody should be
doing everything they can to enhance
that quality of their evening hours and
I found that by sleeping in a tent it's
almost like this hack towards improving
the caliber of my sleep so that I can
show up throughout my day
and Excel be totally focused be totally
present have good energy be in a good
mood and all of that derives from sleep
so if you really take the time to
prioritize the quality and the amount of
time that you're sleeping every night
you will realize quantum gains in your
productivity in your output throughout
your day
if you want to know a few monk secrets
that will change your life check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I think the number
one thing to do is to build the mini
dream first if you try to control the
variety of situations